I WOULD GET RID OF HIS ASS IN
ONE FAIL SWOOP.
>> ONE OF THE BIZARRE PLAYS WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE NBA THIS YEAR
LAST NIGHT.
ASSISTANT COACH FOR THE NETS
KNOCKING THIS PASS AWAY.
>> I THINK THAT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
>> IT IS 5:44 LEFT IN THE GAME.
YOU HAVE A LOT MORE TIME THAN
THE ONE POSSESSION.
>> IT WAS CRAZY.
IT WAS CRAZY.
>> YOU DON'T SEE IT EVERY DAY.
>> I AGREE WITH PROFESSOR CHUCK.
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
PUT YOUR HAND UP FOR A SECOND.
SEE.
IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
>> YOU TOLD ME TO DO IT.
>> YOU THINK IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
>> LOOK AT IT AFTER THE FACT.
WATCH THE REACTION AFTER.
MY BAD.
>> YOU KNOW, THE REFEREE SHOULD
BE PAYING ATTENTION.
>> REFEREE NEXT TO HIM.
>> THEY WON THE GAME BY ONE
POINT.
>> THAT WAS 5 MINUTES AND 44
SECONDS LEFT IN THE GAME.
YOU CAN'T BLAME THAT ONE.
>> THEY WERE SAYING IT.
THEY HAD A WHOLE PRESS
CONFERENCE ABOUT IT.
>> IT WAS AN INTERESTING LOOK.
>> ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS BLAME
FRANK VOGEL OR RUSSELL
WESTBROOK.
>> SPEAKING OF RUSSELL GETTING
BENCHED.
>> I NORMALLY DON'T ROOT AGAINST
TEAMS.
BECAUSE I DON'T GIVE A RATS ASS
WHO WINS THE GAMES.
>> HAVE YOU NOT HEARD THE PHRASE
BEFORE?
>> NORMALLY --
>> CAN I MAKE MY POINT.
>> SMALL.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO PURSUE THAT
FURTHER.
>> SO I NEVER ROOT AGAINST,
BECAUSE I DON'T CARE WHO WINS.
I WANT THE SEASON TO BE OVER SO
WE CAN PLAY GOLF AND FISH.
THE LAKERS ARE SUCH WUSSIES.
THE WAY THEY ARE TRYING TO THROW
RUSSELL WESTBROOK AND FRANK
VOGEL UNDER THE BUS IS PISSING
ME OFF.
>> WE HAVE A GUEST STANDING BY.
>> THE LAKERS STILL SUCK WHEN WE
GET BACK F